moi j'ai réalisé mon rêve c'est que
c'est quoi votre rêve voilà votre rêve
dans la vie c'est quoi matthieu
delormeau toi prendre votre place ben
oui un rêve réalisable
que vous n'êtes pas du sien mort dans le
dans le paddle ouais on est ce pareil
peut-être pendant un an
que je tienne la boutique au chaud
pendant cette année
sera un beau rêve sa belle manne toi le
cul c'est quoi ton
c'est pareil ça c'est si une utopie qui
va prendre ma place j'ai vraiment la
chaîne
vous ne voyez pas que cette pratique des
règles si c'était possible n'est pas là
alors ménard est possible bon alors est
ce possible bon alors couché avec vous
sanaa chaîne n'a pas su opposer quand
même
oui monsieur haddad ah oui monsieur oui
monsieur ben ali khamenei c'est un rêve
un rendez vous quotidien qu ont élaboré
ensemble
les gens pensent qu'elle a qu'à
l'habitude c'est pas poli sans boulot
dans la vie mais bien sûr de boulot le
pana c'est mon boulot en tête bah oui
parle pas quand même nom geste étonnant
vous et intel si beau score en paddle
tout en préparant les missions chaque
jour ça c'est
le bureau et tout un compte du rôle des
soucis avant d aller soucie pas de
bureau les soucis à tout à l'heure et je
le dis aux téléspectateurs j'ai dû
interrompre une partie non parce que le
président de la chaîne m'a pris
quatre ans qu'il attendait et c'est très
bien de 11 heures à dijon
alors d'aldebert habitait série vous
avez décroché mais malheureusement mais
vous êtes trop et manon mais c'est fou
ça mais non pour ses revendications le
bonheur
on y va pour caler le prime time
dans 50 la folie la folie quel est ton
rêve benjamin j'aimerais faire le tour
du monde en bateau ah ouais ouais tu
pouvais pas ouvrir les yeux des gens
[Rires]
c'est pas mieux mais là ça rigolait
il s'est cassé la jambe est tombé dessus
des monts faire une couleur on
rigole kenny g mais je dis moi ce serait
me réincarner en chat est allé gratuit à
la tête de mes voisins pour leur
demander
[Rires]
si vous aussi
vous avez fait un voyage dans le cosmos
numéro vert que vous êtes revenu
n'hésitez pas à venir témoigner kelly
c'est un très beau rêve c'est bon mais
vraiment c'est mignon non mais c'est
vrai c'est vraiment un rêve là parce que
dans les rêves des rêves où on va pas se
raconter on va pas se mentir c'est
n'importe quoi parce que tu rêves en
fait que tu es dans un souvent tu sais
pas pourquoi tu vends tu vois tu es bref
toutes opté dans un champ de maïs ah ben
moi pourquoi pas bien sur wii en effet
le géant vert qui me poursuit
ces matches
j'aimerais qu'ils m'ont soir j'aimerais
qu'ils consomment dans mon rêve c'est
vrai c'est vrai nom mais je vous jure
c'est un rêve récurrent celui ci oui je
l'aï la boîte verte avec 20 d'ici un
mois convaincu tout ça
d'abord je mange le maïs
c'est vrai mais je vous jure ça et après
il comme il est il est très très chaud
il mettait du maïs sur les plus beaux
corps
joue notre saison
donc avec votre guise et un pull bleu
délavé moulant dans vos rêves remettez
de la reprise mais sans qu'une
[Musique]
regarder le géant vert je savais pas que
sa peugeot kader mauvaise foi tu
t'appelles maison secousses compte qu'on
se connaît un peu de me jean kader du
match très sympa un lieu ouvert tout ça
voilà maintenant que vous avez quand
même un souvenir extrêmement précis de
libanais doit renoncer pas dire m
hétérosexuels parfois ou pas
jamais de rêve sexuellement
c est un cauchemar c'est surtout un art
est végétarien
vegan s'arrête voilà je vous le dis
jamais que celui de kelly ouais je peux
me permettre qu'il veut pro de ça ouais
réincarné en chatte est allé chez le
voisin a demandé du lait le lait la
mamelle mam elle m'a manqué dix mamelles
maman besoin de maternité de maternité
désir d'enfant voiture est venue elle
c'est
vraiment fou et bien sûr et moi le viol
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce grand club
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
toi portage
wii qu'est-ce qu'il veut ces voitures à
évaluer vraiment possible c'est de me
marier et le rêve possible c'est de me
taper genton
[Applaudissements]
cette dernière c'était le
vernir à quelques encablures la saison
sur deux vous tient plus à vous faire
après l'action et
la logistique
les mots ouais ben haim camotos à deux
doigts de sortir beinheim je te le dis
tu vas avoir annoncé qu donc toi ton
rêvasser ça va très bien alors daniel
daniel tu adores tu es magnifique mais
là tu as coiffer quitte à maquiller la
selaçao mais attends là on a
l'impression c'est franchement là on ne
voit pas à l'acheter là on a voulu en
fin de soirée le show
[Applaudissements]
tournée comptera plaisir on a boulogne
on débute ce
matin vous les 7 changer de couleur de
cheveux après vous l'entretenez pas
c'est que seymour
je ne sais pas où tu as vu que j'ai fait
que je suis dit
faut revenir à temps mais c'est vrai
mais c'est pas un chien
toile est belle non mais combien ça
coûte non mais tu sais comment ça nos
coûts
qu'est ce qui vous chagrine là je ne
sais pas
les manifs le pôle aura bien les yeux
frère ben les yeux c'est quoi
ces tentatives de temps plus rien toi
t'es belle nature est par contre
beaucoup j'aime bien voir un paquet
énergie doit retenir mais je crois à ce
qu'elle en fait le positif c'est que je
vais bien aimé quand je reviendrai en
bruits
mais pas tous malades aura besoin de son
père et moi tout le monde me dit moi je
suis moi j'ai un pote qui m'a dit moi tu
vois je suis fou de good way et ben
daniels depuis qu'elle est blonde de ses
rivaux à croquer comme une chips
toujours il m'est rien arrivé
non mais sans lui et là tu es au top
c'est juste une question de coiffure
enfin shampoing viol est un champion
blue tu sais ces contrées des couleurs
comme envisat encore et bleu suppose
qu'elle était rose lui qu'il faut à
chaque fois bleus pour facta couleurs
des bornes
tu m'as négoce et ailleurs
mais c'est vrai match est peut-être
raison mais pas du tout je le sais
pourquoi pas ce que j'ai fait des
couleurs où ça vient
je ne sais plus que
jamais l'autre voilà
maintenant une année catastrophique
alors qu'est ce qu'elle veut c'est quoi
son m on le connaît pas de me
transformer en géant vert pour être dans
vos rêves
[Applaudissements]
voilà
cinémale en estimation
mais quoi mais qu'est ce que tu veux
être moins
20 points n'ont pas vu la chemise
ouverte
elles mêmes les poils très belle moi
j'aime bien les blondes
est peut-être encore deux trois jours
est-ce que trois mois
ça va pas se faire tout de suite hein
c'est vendre un mot que non vraiment il
faut que je m'habitue moi j'arrive là
dessus donc pas dole huawei au vous
commencé les blondes par mathieu après
mon passé je vais pas commencer pourquoi
tu veux
obama
si vous les blondes moi j'aimerais bien
avoir un instant à toi sinon
on attendra sera huit nouveaux camions
bordel pas possible j'adore ses
émissions que je kiffe mon coeur est
intense et seront tous 15 ses
restaurants à moi ou les gens
viendraient en rigolant et gelé
s'ouvrait avec comme je parle beaucoup
il est saoul et les gens sont obligés
sympa mais finnois ouvrir un garage de
voitures dans le sud ben voilà
qui méritait à trouver des lunettes dans
ma poche je ne sais pas mal mais pas nul
[Rires]
oh
ap
oui
et na
waie des sardines dans ses rêves à
mykonos a pas pensé un terreau
c'est à nous tous à queue
mais pas sans défaut aux bêtes et moi
aimons qu'une moto la finalité mettez
moi ça ouais ouais
c'est quoi c'est la musique d'attenté
vous avez demandé
terres de fenêtre
terres de fenêtre c'est plus de 150
professionnels à votre écoute lorsque
vous fenêtre soit en toute sécurité chez
vous posez un passage
ne quittez pas un spécialiste de la snet
à vous répondre
hélas lors il pose une question
savez vous que grâce à la photosynthèse
quel est votre rêve un gland ping à quoi
bon ouais un gland ping en fait un un
camping un peu glamour oui c'est ça dans
les cyclades un peu chic avec des loges
avec des terrains teny des terrains de
paddle on peut faire n'importe quand
même mis un peu au delà mais les gangs
quand même ce lien eh ben c'est à dire
qu'en fait ce n'est pas un hôtel c'est
des structures molle
turmoil d'accord mais voilà comme
l'essor de petites caravanes des
écolodges et tout ça est dans la nature
comme ça au bord de l'eau et ont occupé
quand je serai vieille donc dans pas
très longtemps
mais tout est chiant là dedans
géraldine bien en faire une fête ça
ouais récupère les trucks
qui va alors lui c'est quoi son à moi ça
reste qui a failli se réaliser cette
égérie d'une marque de mode
et la marque est fermé non j'ai été
contacté par une marque grande taille à
strasbourg vous appelle tout beau tout
rose
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ah
ouais et alors ça c'est parce que des
vêtements était trop petit a
rabaissé pas mal de bonnes idées c'est
assez sa tombe est un parti est
milliardaire comme vous aussi non
[Rires]
voilà mais du coup vous avez plus de
rêve non sinon c'est quoi votre rêve
c'est horrible je suis chez moi et le
club sans c'est pas top mais à part ça à
part ça viendrait monsieur compagne
attend à trois ans de vous c'est moi on
nous doit tout direz-vous rien moi j'ai
tout dit je vous ai dit mon rêve ça
n'aurait apparemment vous êtes une
huître cyril coomans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais c'était plus jolie la comparaison
de l'huître parce que lui et rien à
perdre ouais
j'en rajoute
jamais mangé de moules huîtres
informer communiquer voulait dire comme
les coquilles saint-jacques my soul
c'est plus rare
ouais on a fait avec tant rêve c'est
quoi ton rêve alors pourquoi je n'étais
plus et chaque but 1 passe romaine à ce
que ces sexuelle est ce que c'est sorti
c'est l'argent est ce que c'est un bon
sert l'amour
avec un grand a c'est mon mari venait
si vous avez commencé marier comme tu as
10 2 ans à 1 voie de l'amour on est
tranquille deux ans tu as dit non il ya
dix a
vite arrêté deux ans
jeudi 7
mai oui mais oui bah justement et c'est
justement quoi je vais en parler à un
tueur à dos ça du tout bougeait pas si
je vais rester deux ans des biens terme
j'ai un rêve amoureux
mais pas ses crises de leur histoire à
eau s'entassent mais non virtuel en mai
avec la rente est pas du tout bon
d'autres enfants non pas du tout vous
rêvez de rencontrer quelqu'un qui ne
vous connaît pas qui vous a jamais vus
et qui est vous avez attendu et voilà
que vous êtes qui vous aiment pas votre
argent vous êtes connu à jour de padt a
pas du tout
ça alors ça ça ne me dérange pas du tout
non non vous voulez vous marier mais non
il n'y a jamais fait ils bafouent côté
milliards da te marie pas s'est cassé
alors tout perdre je ne suis pas
milliardaire breton pas un oeuf non mais
christian
marié 15 pas maintenant pas un homme
c'est du kiss paul eluard
encore lu mais je vous chauffe depuis
tout à l'heure
la faute à la neige
c'est l'exacte origine regina le disais
je ne rêve pas j'agis
c'est ce que vous faites avec nous on va
continuer à rêver
[Applaudissements]